[Music]
hey everybody this is Nick De Santis
from the hustle thanks for tuning in to
another episode of behind the hustle the
show where we bring you inside some of
the stories that we are working on and
introduce you to some of the interesting
people in our world so for today's
episode I wrote a story last for a
newsletter last week about the 54
billion dollar wedding industry that has
really really fallen on hard times right
now obviously and that's true of pretty
much anybody that's associated with the
events world knows what this is about
you have couples across the country that
are canceling their wedding plans or in
some cases postponing them and it's
really sort of thrown the entire
industry into a little bit of chaos but
in some cases there are a few couples
who decided to go through with their
weddings anyway using technology like
zoom or Facebook live or some of the
other platforms that are out there and
what was especially interesting about
this story is that after we published it
last week one of our readers reached out
to us and said yeah actually me and my
my wife we actually did this a couple
days ago and we'd love to talk to you
about it and I thought their story was
really interesting and and wanted to
share with all of you so I'm here to
welcome in dan-and-jenn Wilson who live
in Orlando Florida and we'll be
celebrating two weeks as newlyweds on
this coming Saturday welcome to you both
thank you thanks for having us yeah I
really appreciate it so I think the
first thing that I want to ask you is
something that everybody wants to know
and we talked about a little bit the
other days how did the two of you meet
yeah so we met so how fitting for a
virtual wedding is we actually met
online so a dating site tinder which I'm
sure everyone was familiar with so
tinder actually works so yeah I was
actually moving to Jacksonville and so
that was I wanted to meet new people and
I met Dan my first week there so worked
out well anything in particular stand
out about that first tinder date I know
that some people have
memorable first dates the most normal
data yeah I think both did a pretty good
job of you know setting up profiles and
such a way to I guess attract people
that were maybe like-minded and you know
we did I think for a bit of text
screening beforehand to see if you know
someone can actually complete a thought
or have similar interests and things
like that before we met face to face so
it's a pretty normal dinner yeah yeah
tell us a little bit about the proposal
and sort of then what went into the the
planning yeah so yeah it's something
yeah it's kind of been on my mind you
know so it's April this month this is
six years we've been together and over
the last couple years I know it's you
know something I've been wanting to move
forward with and you know asked you to
marry me and there was really no
question in my mind that that's the
route I wanted to go but it was you know
trying to think through the different
options of how to propose and you know
something that's maybe more practical
versus you know something romantic and
things like that so you know just it
didn't quite have a good feeling of how
to do it until really last summer so
we're on vacation in Colorado and you
know I thought yeah this I think could
be you know a good time and you know
basically went and got a ring
Akil over and we you know that's the
silicon rings that way so I went to a
running store in the morning before we
went for a hike and you know bought a
couple rings just hoping to determine
which size and you know style she might
like I'll grab a couple you know see
what happens and you know she was
looking at the other part of the store
so he went to the cashier I need to buy
these really really quick you know cuz
that would kind of ruin everything
so got him shopping them on my pocket
and we got to walked around and then
went on our hike and you know just had
them in my pocket and you know just as
we got towards kind of higher elevations
the people on the trail started to thin
out and I say well I better do this
pretty soon while I can you know
convince some some kids at college kids
you know so gave them my camera to take
to take video and then Jen gave them
Kirk here Monaco we'd get her picture
you know so I wanted to be a video and
then she got pictures on hers and you
know yeah it was I was completely
surprised I was like why do you want
video what do you want a video for we'll
just take pictures it was very sweet
very cool very cool so you told me a
little bit about sort of what you had
planned for the wedding obviously I
don't think anybody goes into planning
their wedding thinking that Facebook
live or zoom is really gonna play a role
in the celebration but you guys found
yourself in that in that situation
pretty quickly so tell us a little bit
about sort of what you were planning and
then how quickly you had to turn when
once you realize that that was not
really going to be an option right so we
we had planned a smaller wedding about
50 people since we met in Jacksonville
we decided that's where we wanted to
have it it was going to be simple
married in a park and then have the
reception at one of our favorite
breweries in the and a backroom area
there and we started to get kind of text
messages and calls from some friends who
were planning on coming to the wedding
and said you know gee I don't I don't
think I'm gonna be able to come with
everything it was just starting to
happen so for I would say quite a while
we thought we would still get married
same day maybe you know smaller amount
of people would be there but it became
very clear quickly that we wouldn't be
able to do that so we very much planned
and then kind of unplanned and pivoted
the entire wedding just let people know
that we weren't going to be able to have
it one we didn't feel comfortable having
it in two week we couldn't have if we
wanted to because the brewery and all
the restaurants and all of that
obviously what we're closed or just
doing very takeout type of things so
that's when we decided to kind of pivot
and for us our decision was
but us the two of us were the most
important things and so we still wanted
to get married and we figured we could
use technology in order to do that yeah
I would say one of the things that was
cool is your your whole ceremony is
posted to Facebook and you can go and
watch it and I did that and it was
beautiful and it looked great and one of
the things that was actually really cool
about it is you could see in the
comments threads underneath the video
there was sort of anticipation starting
to build as people were taking selfies
with drinks and cheering you on tell us
a little bit about sort of what that was
like to see that anticipation build-up
yeah yeah it was cool I mean it you know
I think of someone we created the event
you know so kind of pivoting and a
little bit from something where you know
we wanted a smaller in-person wedding
again is because of costs and and they
new restrictions as far as size and
things like that but since you know we
made a decision ago virtual it was like
well let's open up to two more people
and invite people to watch and so that
was kind of neat to include more people
that you know I guess it's not that they
were better friends or not or whatever
but just you know maybe people that
would have had challenges you know
traveling further or you know with with
family obligations or work obligation
thing like this I felt like we would
actually share it within a broader
grouped and maybe we would have in
person with a little bit smaller group
that way yeah yeah so I mean it was
awesome to see the virtual part of it
and everyone and we also did have there
a couple people in the neighborhood who
were friends with who figured out where
we were doing it at who showed up
obviously from a very far distance but
we're still able to watch so that also
made it pretty cool and so tell us a
little bit about sort of the there's an
interesting moment where you're actually
like you're going live on Facebook tell
us a little bit about the technology set
up and how you actually were able to
navigate that from the moment where
you're you know you're Hertz probably
beating out of your chest with and then
you're in a situation where you have to
make the texture that the technology
works yeah we we did FaceTime with our
friend who
was marrying us and he was in
Jacksonville so we had one screams that
was used for FaceTime and then we had
the computer and we used that for
Facebook to livestream we actually had
done a trial run a couple days before I
think and we also had to figure out
where we could get Wi-Fi in the
neighborhood and have a backdrop that
looks you know somewhat nice for
ceremony solos all the logistics of
figuring that out the end time of day
because it's Florida and it's already
pretty hot so if I'm not mistaken so
that was you know intentional because
you know with the jacket on and you know
clothing and you know I was already
sweating like crazy anyway so but we had
a little pre-production check on you
know it's technology just to kind of see
well it should work it looks like we've
got pretty good Wi-Fi let's let's cross
our fingers and hope it stands up yeah
it seemed to work so the technology went
really smoothly were there other sort of
logistical bumps in the road that you
hit you know there's all sort of
essentials around a cake and flowers and
a dress and did you have any trouble
with those essentials well the night
before we went to the grocery store and
got our wedding cake and flowers okay I
would say probably 15 minutes before the
wedding the gardener went by with the
blower so that was a little
nerve-wracking that's not gonna work and
then for us an important part of our
wedding was our dog as well so she we
brought her and thought that she would
kind of settle down but she she went
crazy she kind of was just like doing
laps and then in the area there and yeah
I wanted to be right next to us and the
only other hiccup and we talked earlier
in your dress was yeah the dress well
the the Jets had gotten lost oh there
were yeah there were some things we had
to do we
it ended up I got the dress which was
amazing and it was beautiful but yeah it
was a scary month of don't know what I'm
gonna wear
hopefully not something that had to come
together at the eleventh hour like the
cake so tell us a little bit about sort
of the reaction that you had from
friends and family I'm sure there were
people who were bummed obviously that
they couldn't be there in person but as
I said earlier the ease of connectivity
makes it potentially more-- more easy
for people to participate if maybe there
were you know they had to come in from
from from farther away so I'm curious
sort of what you heard from friends and
family about how it went yeah I actually
think it was it was awesome I so we had
so many comments on our Facebook page
and from as Dan mentioned from people
acquaintances co-workers that I actually
feel like it made the day extra special
to have so many comments and people post
and like you saw the photos and people
celebrating and even FaceTime with folks
afterwards who wanted to talk with us
and sharing the experience I thought it
was awesome yeah no I agree I think it
was just a great experience to a broader
group of you know friends and family and
co-workers and ex co-workers and things
like that I kind of our circle that we
could share the day with and from the
from the ceremony standpoint and I think
we still you know we envision having an
in-person celebration party if you will
hopefully this fall at some point you
know in when schedules you know kind of
a line but you know for the day I
thought it was great to be able to share
it that way that's great
so you went through the ceremony
obviously went through and went off
without a hitch but one thing that we
talked about the other day is the the
the shutdowns did disrupt your honeymoon
plans that too yes yeah we we had a trip
to Germany plans so we both are in
triathlon and I was fortunate enough to
get into a race in Roth's Germany
challenge Roth and
that was been July fifth and so we were
gonna do the race on the front end and
stay extra in honeymoon in Germany so
that got canceled recently which I
figured it was going to probably a month
or so ago just because of the state of
the world there's no way they'll have it
so so the honeymoon is on been deferred
for a little bit we've got to figure out
when it be planning the wedding we're so
still I'm gonna do the race next year
but you know maybe we do something yeah
we will probably do a honeymoon whenever
we can travel at least somewhere yeah
yeah well I hope that the race does go
well when you're able to to get back to
it next year
so one of the things I'm also curious to
hear your perspective on a little bit is
where we're edging into prime wedding
season in the US and there are a lot of
couples who are having to make similar
choices to the ones that you did so I'd
be curious for for other couples who
might be in your shoes thinking about do
we do this virtually do we postpone what
are some of the factors that you would
recommend other people weigh and what
advice would you have for other folks
who are in your shoes you know I think
you know as we said here in early to
mid-april you know weddings that may be
planned for for May and then probably
into June I think are pretty pretty high
likelihood that they're probably not
gonna go off as planned with you know
especially than anything of size you
know as it is I think our personal
opinion is you know the virus kind of
you know plateaus and settles down a
little bit I don't know that it'll be an
overnight you know rush back to you know
sporting events of thousands of people
or congregations of you know 50 100 200
300 people for a wedding right so you
know I think over the next couple months
you know as restrictions lifts it might
be more of a smaller venue more intimate
so if if that is what the couple is
looking to do you know perhaps you can
you know still accommodate something
like that but you know I think anything
larger than that near-term
you know is gonna have to either be
deferred to later in the year or look at
you know other options like like virtual
or you know kind of downsizing for now
and you know down the road having a a
larger event then you may be a little
different but you know yeah I think
it'll come down to personal preference
and what's important to the couple is it
having everybody there in person and if
it is it maybe deferring it but I will
say that doing it virtually I know we
were both disappointed we couldn't have
friends and family there together but in
the end it was such a special day for us
all the comments all the videos you know
people just driving by and honking and
you know saying hey congrats it just
made the day special it was just in a
different way so I think it's just
preference on on how you want to do it
and how you plan for it I know the
logistics on all you know big weddings
is a lot more so that's the other thing
is just talking with vendors and
figuring out you know what they can do
and can they do it laters and how that
all plays out so big consideration when
you have a wedding especially if it's a
big one
so it'll you'll be celebrating two weeks
on Saturday but it's been you know I
would imagine two weeks in quarantine
and self-isolation
so how have the past two weeks been for
the two of you okay great I mean you
know I think it's more star status quo
to some degree and then we you know been
together now six years and yeah I think
it's it's nice to have kind of a special
bond you know so but I think kind of the
day-to-day you know it's not terribly
different other than you know we're kind
of cooped up a little bit and
fortunately here not here in Florida we
we are able to get out and you know go
for a run and you know we have the
weather that we can do that you know go
for a bike ride or something like that
certainly you know keeping your distance
from people and things like that so we
you know we can get a getaway a little
bit if we need to but I think it's been
great so
I agree it's been an awesome two weeks
we tried to make the day of extra
special and feel that way and I I feel
like it did it and then we kind of got
back into the normal group of things so
have you thought oh uh one thing that I
people always ask me is sort of what are
the first couple things that you're
gonna do when you're able to like be out
in society again have you thought about
that at all
it's a good question yeah I know for me
like he had mentioned we're triathletes
so it's that time of year when there's a
lot of races and be nice to do a race
and traveling I know for me I would love
to just go somewhere get out a little
bit more yeah
I say you know see friends you know get
together so you know some of the local
spots you know restaurants universe bars
you know spots that we have you know
kind of the regulars and friends and
such that we see typically that you know
we haven't been able to kind of catch up
with and you know meet up with first
language would be you know be nice to
kind of be able to do that again so well
we'll all look forward to it I really
appreciate you all coming on and telling
us about your special day it's it's
we're just in such a sort of an
unbelievable time right now and I'm glad
that the given the tough choices that
the two of you had to make and sort of
it didn't work out maybe wasn't your
ideal it was still something that you
can look back on and it's sort of
special in its own right yeah definitely
absolutely yeah thanks for having us
Nick resolutions to both of you and
thanks for coming on really appreciate
it yeah thank you thank you take care
yeah
[Music]